Boo Boo Migrant
stay
amaran
Live is
also a traditional culture.
Well, when you're happy, mochi is really a part of it.
Delicious mochi is soft and
stretches well. If you pull it, it stretches well.
[Music]
Boo Bar  Well, it's not, but in some areas, it's easy
to attach toys
. Well, there are various characters with rice cakes, but in
general, one person is attached from the beginning and one person is ponnell.
There is no practice with this face letter.
Well, it was said that it was twisted three times a second
.
This is the trick of foreign capital, that is the only timing.
In order to get the timing,
I'll do that while calling
out to you. It's a small thing. It's a
true ball game. Yes,
it's a toy. That's right. Anyone can do
it.  It should be [music] because it has rice cakes
. I think that the face when eating delicious food has a unique human face, but I'm happiest to see other things.
[Music]
Po
]  Hmm